bueno había una detrás mío se puede ver
todavía algo de militantes que se
encuentran aquí frente a los tribunales
de comodoro pide donde salió esta
sentencia que como bien decís era tan
esperada se escucharon muchos cantos de
Cristina presidenta Cristina presidenta
y un sector muy fuerte de la militancia
que sigue pidiéndole a ella que sea
candidata en 2023 estamos escuchando el
abogado constitucionalista dando algunas
explicaciones de qué va a poder y qué no
va a poder hacer en principio hay que
esperar como decíamos una sentencia
definitiva de las mayor instancia que es
la Corte Suprema también había algunos
algunos llamados a otros sectores del
del cristianismo Si se quiere porque no
estaban aquí presentes preguntando dónde
estaban y estaban también hablando de la
posibilidad de trasladarse de aquí hacia
el senado de la nación donde se estaba
esperando la palabra de la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández que ya
había dicho que iba a hablar después de
la sentencia era una sentencia esperada
pero no deja de enojar de indignar y de
preocupar a la militancia aquí presente
y en general la militancia quiere
señorita absolutamente le contamos esto
también audiencia como bien decías
natalio estaba anunciado y se espera
para los próximos momentos las
declaraciones de la propia
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner que está previsto que lo haga a
través de sus redes sociales contanos
natalio cómo viene siendo nos contabas
del clima social no sobre todo de los
sectores afines a Cristina Fernández
pero que pasa a nivel político en el
arco político cómo viene siendo el clima
sobre todo en estos días previos a que
se conozca la sentencia y la verdad que
hay un clima bastante enrarecido digamos
por un lado Cristina Fernández venía
insistiendo mucho desde el inicio que
acá hay una persecución política y una
suerte de complot de sectores de la
oposición para tratar de
dificultarle su carrera hacia una
eventual presidencia por ejemplo o que
la quieren ver presa no siempre hace
comparaciones con lo que ocurrió con
Lula da Silva en Brasil por dar por dar
un ejemplo concreto de la región del
otro lado del Arco político dicen que si
es culpable se tiene que hacer cargo de
lo de lo que sucedió y vamos a ver lo
que sucede en los últimos días en el día
domingo salieron unas informaciones
sobre unos supuestos chats filtrados
entre funcionarios del poder judicial y
personas de funcionariado de la ciudad
de Buenos Aires de la oposición que
estaban tratando de Si se quiere tapar
un encuentro que había ocurrido en en la
Patagonia Y ustedes me preguntarán por
qué estamos hablando de esto ahora bueno
porque en ese supuesto encuentro según
lo que especulan sobre todo los sectores
más cercanos al kirchnerismo se reunían
personas opuestas al al cristianismo al
peronismo al gobierno con intenciones de
hacer algún tipo de acuerdo para tratar
de llegar a resultados judiciales como
este No necesariamente ese encuentro en
Bariloche pero así los protagonistas son
señalados constantemente por el
oficialismo y sobre todo por el
kirchnerismo de estar tratando de
contratar en contra de la vicepresidenta
y estas acusaciones entre oposición la
actual oposición y el oficialismo
cruzadas de espionaje de complot de
operaciones son constantes como te digo
enrareciendo y esto también ayuda en ese
sentido un clima político bastante
complejo especialmente de Cara a un año
2023 que elecciones presidenciales Así
que vamos a estar muy atentos A cómo se
sigue desarrollando la situación aquí en
Argentina clave natalio esto que nos
contabas este último episodio de
polémica no de este viaje que también
según trascendió habría estado
financiado por El multimedio Clarín uno
de los medios digamoslo no con de mayor
oposición al kirchnerismo y al gobierno
de Cristina Fernández natalio es posible
no que ocurra una suerte de vigilancia
No que los sectores afines a Cristina
Fernández continúen A partir de estos
días en las calles o por lo menos en su
residencia allá en la capital Federal
verdad
Mira vamos a ver qué ocurre con eso sí
hablaban de un estado de una suerte de
estado de movilización permanente
especialmente desde la cámpora que es el
sector más afín que dirige su hijo
máximo kirchner pero la cámpora no
estuvo presente de acá eso le reclamaban
los sectores kirchneristas que estaban
en este lugar que vayan a ir a la casa o
no hay que ver porque porque generó
muchísimos conflictos cuando empezó
manifestaciones permanentes en torno a
la casa de Cristina Fernández y a lo
mejor bajan el mensaje de que no en la
casa no posiblemente vamos a ver Tal vez
sí digo pero no es algo definido es
Dinámico seguramente vamos a ver
movilizaciones permanentes tal vez ahora
en el congreso se estén dando
movilizaciones Y a lo largo de estos
meses que vienen siga habiendo
manifestaciones fuertes y como vos decís
una suerte de blindaje de la militancia
en torno a Cristina Fernández que era
algo que ya estaba ocurriendo en el
marco del juicio y también empezó a
ocurrir con mucha fuerza en el contexto
del atentado contra su vida que ocurrió
a principios de septiembre un hecho que
Cristina misma no vinculó también a todo
este proceso que según ella habría
estado plagado de irregularidades
natalio hay otra figura clave en esta
causa no Además de otros 12 acusados que
es Lázaro báez verdad podemos contarle a
nuestra audiencia internacional
brevemente quién es
es una persona cercana a la familia
kirchner de su provincia de Santa Cruz
en la Patagonia Argentina una persona
que En sus orígenes trabajaba en el
sector bancario y con el tiempo comenzó
a tener la posibilidad de acceder a
contratos de obra pública importantes en
la provincia de Santa Cruz y justamente
la primera sospecha alrededor de la
figura de Lázaro es como un empleado
bancario Por más jerárquico que haya
podido ser de repente se transforma en
un empresario de la construcción que
accede a licitaciones importantes en la
provincia y los señalamientos contra las
argode tienen que ver con que justamente
recibía una suerte de favores para poder
acceder a esos contratos a cambio de
algún tipo de de pago ayuda de evolución
Habría que ver digamos de hecho Si se
quiere esta causa en sí va va en ese
sentido tiene que ver con la convivencia
entre funcionarios y esta estructura de
Lázaro báez de obra pública para
favorecerlo de forma irregular Esa es la
figura de Lázaro báez que también está
dentro de este proceso es uno de los
grandes protagonistas de toda esta causa
natalio y a lo largo de la jornada ya
desde temprano no por la mañana
funcionarios también
líderes de sectores sindicales
organizaciones de trabajo han estado
manifestando su apoyo a Cristina
Fernández cierto también líderes
internacionales como Evo Morales bueno
por supuesto tiene muchos líderes
internacionales muy afines del sector
más progresista de izquierda de la
región que van a estar siempre
apoyándola y esta gente que está detrás
mío caminó 17 km en un día de muchísimo
calor creo que es algo Bastante evidente
es un día muy muy muy pesado en la
ciudad de Buenos Aires desde una zona
llamada linier cerca de las afueras de
la ciudad de Buenos Aires hasta aquí
hasta el centro pasando el centro de la
ciudad cerca del río de la plata para
manifestarse en respaldo de la
vicepresidenta y hubo otras este
movilizaciones vigilias vamos a ir
viendo a lo largo del día si se van
sumando otros sectores que todavía no
parecen haber salido a la calle porque
recordemos que
el cristianismo pero también el frente
de todos ambos el frente de todos que es
la coalición de gobierno el cristianismo
que es una de las patas peronistas que
forman parte de esta coalición a su vez
está dividido en varios subsectores que
se suman a la movilización y no todos
actúan necesariamente en forma
coordinada si salieran todos a la vez
esto sería realmente Una un mundo de
gente por ahora es una manifestación
razonablemente importante que se
concentra en este lugar hay que ver si
empieza a tomar más y más la calle el
sector que apoya Cristina Fernández y se
van sumando todos estos subsectores que
componen por un lado el cristianismo y
por el otro lado del frente de